hey you guys
time for a movie retrospective going way
back in time for this one
1960s peeping tom
now this is one that kind of came up i
think this came up in the patreon polls
like several times but for some reason
like this week
it got like a really lot of votes so i
guess people wanted us to
talk about this this is a movie that
the kind of the story behind it is like
almost as interesting as the movie is
because the director of this it's a
british movie
came out the same year as uh psycho and
the two movies are usually like grouped
together as being kind of uh
sort of proto slasher movies um because
a lot of things that
you know came about in the horror genre
like later on were kind of first
done in these two movies so it's a
british film it was directed by michael
powell
now prior to him directing this movie
um he was actually like a really well
respected
uh british director he had done a movie
called um
he done the red shoes which i think got
oscar nominated for best picture like in
the late 1940s i believe it was
and he had made like a lot of really
well-regarded films
however when this movie came out very
famously
it pretty much tanked his entire career
it's hard to imagine nowadays the
vitriol that critics
leveled at this movie and
i guess nowadays like with the benefit
of hindsight i mean
you know from today's perspective
obviously when everyone's seen
you know torture porn and the human
centipede and everything like that
this movie is very tame but for the time
even though it's not particularly bloody
or it's not particularly violent
critics really were very very
offended i guess by
not only the fact that i guess the film
is like putting you
in the shoes of a serial killer in the
sense that you're seeing things from his
point of view
also that you're also kind of not
i don't know if you're supposed to like
sympathize with him but he is almost a
sympathetic
character not not in the sense that
they're saying in the movie that what
he's doing is okay
but they're making him seem like a
rounded human being with a problem
rather than a monster which as far as i
know
was maybe the first mainstream movie to
do that i'm not real sure
well he was created yeah so
that part of the movie is pretty
accurate serial killer is kind of
created by an environment and that it
gets into that he's kind of the creation
an experimental creation of his dad
who was a biologist that was that's part
of it that's why it turned out that way
which look the movie's kind of dated
um i don't think it aged as well as
psycho i think
psycho is a lot more direct to the point
and uh
but doesn't give as many details this
was this movie's a little more
complicated than psycho
it is yeah it's got more characters
there's a lot more backstory
so it's not quite as streamlined and
doesn't leave as much to the imagination
as psycho does
uh i think psycho's a little more
artistic but this isn't a bad movie i
can see it's an important movie
especially in the genre in the horror
genre oh yeah big time
i mean i i feel like and what ended up
happening with it
as i said the when it came out in 1960
the critics were so
horrified by it that
um it was essentially pulled from
theaters
it was supposed to be released in the us
but i don't think it ever was or it just
got like a very very um
you know limited release the only reason
i think
that people still like talk about it
today and know about it today
is that in the 1970s um
martin scorsese was he said well
you know there was this rumor about the
movie because we had heard about it
but you couldn't really see it anywhere
because they didn't really release it
over here
so he's like so i was friends with this
guy who was like a producer i don't
remember what
you know uh what studio he worked at but
he had like the only print in the united
states of this movie it was like a 16
millimeter print
so he had obtained it because he had
heard about the reputation
and originally they were going to remake
it like do an american remake
but i guess they screened it and martin
score says he was at this
screening and the guy that was
originally gonna
like remake it was just kind of like
well i can't top that
so maybe we should just release it so
martin scorsese actually in 1979
he was instrumental in getting this
movie screened at the new york
film festival and also for paying for it
to be re-released
because he was like really into it yeah
20 years after it's official
yeah so i feel like if it hadn't been
for him um
i don't know if people would still be
like talking about this movie nowadays
and
like i said it's um very famous because
it you know quote unquote ruined michael
powell's career even though like i said
he had been like nominated for oscars
and [ __ ] like that prior to that
the interesting thing is that he doesn't
michael powell didn't seem to be like
all that pissed off about it he was like
oh well that kind of sucks but he just
went on he didn't i don't think he ever
directed another movie but he
still worked in the movie business and
[ __ ] like that so he doesn't seem to
have
taken it too much like you know everyone
sucks and i'm just like i hate all you
guys he was just like yeah
[ __ ] happens he's just kind of like
which you know that seemed like a very
healthy attitude to have you seen he
survived
up until the time they re-released i'm
not sure if he did or not um
they i saw like i was watching a thing
with uh mark carmode who is a very
famous uh british film critic
and he's really into this movie and he
was interviewing martin scorsese about
it and also
interviewed um michael powell's wife at
the time who she sounded american so i
guess he had an american wife at the
time she was also like a film editor
and um she said something about um
about him dying but i don't remember
what year that was so i kind of hope
that
you know he was alive to see like this
get rediscovered
but i don't know if he actually was
because it was so much later
so let's kind of get so what this movie
is about
is there is a guy it's set in london
there's a guy named mark lewis now he's
played by a german actor
who is billed as carl bim i guess
um i don't think that's his real name
but it's like a a more
anglicized version of his german name
something that i
didn't know but i think um someone
mentioned to me
was that another thing that was very
shocking about this movie in europe at
least was that
this particular actor had been in a
bunch of movies in germany but he always
played like real wholesome
parts like boy next door type hero type
roles
so the fact that he would play a serial
killer
was also another thing that was kind of
contributing to like the sleaziness of
this
kind of [ __ ] so even though the movie
and if you see the poster and [ __ ] like
that they kind of
it seemed like they were trying to
market it
as sort of like an exploitation kind of
flick
but it wasn't really like that it was
more like a psychological
um you know kind of exploration
of this dude's uh you know his
[ __ ] up it is you know what i mean
this character reminds me of a real life
serial killer
that russia had it was that crazy dude
that was sawing the little boy's feet in
half and hanging him
oh yeah that's how i imagined that guy
being it was kind of like this
yeah yeah you remember he's he made
films what he was doing yeah yeah yeah i
think i remember the guy's name it
happened much later
yeah yeah the character in this movie
kind of
makes me think of that dude that russian
guy because this dude is like the way
he's portrayed and when
you know when i said before like he's
almost portrayed sympathetically
um it's kind of like this clean cut dude
very soft spoken right but he's not
violent not
obnoxious not anything like that he
seems almost like very
uh you know socially anxious he's a
little you know isolated he's a little
um you know introverted uh so he comes
across like that so what he does for a
job
he's actually a focus puller like at a
um like kind of a bigger
filmmaking studio and on the side in the
evenings
he also does smut pictures
because i guess there's this uh news
agents and
that's where you go to get like the
illicit naked pictures and [ __ ] like you
used to have to like
[ __ ] under the counter yeah um so he
photographs those
and it's interesting because he's always
really nice toward the girls
like that he's photographing um oh also
notable i think this movie was the first
british film to show female like
full frontal female nudity it's very
very brief yeah it's not a big deal
but it's not but i mean it was kind of
like the first one to show that so that
was another thing that everyone was like
up in arms about because like i said in
1960 um
so so he's doing that and he is also
um on the side on the side because you
know even back then they had a gig
economy i guess
he was also a serial killer so um it
comes out later on that
he became a serial killer and
particularly one that was interested in
voyeurism um because his dad
and i wonder if they i was wondering
while i was watching this
i wondered if they based the dude's dad
on one of those weird like scientists i
can't remember i don't think it was bf
skinner but it might have been like
somebody like that
that decided they were gonna raise their
kid like in a box or some kind of crap
like that you know what i mean
like to see how it would turn out it's
kind of like that sort of thing
so the dad was like a voyer as well and
i think it's implied like near the end
that the dad was also a serial killer or
he was interested in
eliciting fear in people and like he was
interested in studying people's fear
responses
so so basically you find out that when
mark was a little kid
his dad would basically film him 24 7
like all the time because he says you
know i never got any privacy or anything
like that
and then he would try to do [ __ ] like
you know he'd wake him up at night by
like flashing lights in his face or like
throwing a lizard on him or something
like that to see what would happen
because he was like really really
fascinated with
you know a child's fear response and he
wrote like all these books about it he
made like all these films about it
and so it's almost like mark is like
carrying on
the work you know what i'm saying so the
house that he lives in
it's now a boarding house but you find
out like subsequently
that the dad that mark's dad owned this
house
and now now that he's dead like mark is
living there and he
like rents out the rooms because he
can't really afford to like keep the
house going because it's really big
so he has all like all these tenants now
it comes to pass that this young woman
who lives with her mother
in one of the rooms on the ground floor
um mark kind of takes a shine to her and
she kind of takes a shine to him as well
even though he's super weird and super
awkward
and you would think that like nowadays
most women would like run screaming away
from the dude because he just seems
really strange
but she's kind of into him she says he
kind of has a quality
it was a simpler time i guess it was and
there wasn't like a i guess maybe there
wasn't a lot of
[ __ ] people picked from people to pick
from
they're like because she was like oh he
just seems kind of gentle and all this
other kind of stuff
well the girls that were the the models
that he dealt with were kind of
odd too i think a lot of the characters
i i don't think the movie aged that well
i mean i
i i recognize movie but a lot of the
characters i think they're kind of
written in an unrealistic way
the the uh the what he called the models
that he worked with yeah
mostly just complained and kind of
kicked him around
uh you're not really sure whether or not
they were attracted to him or not it was
really hard to figure out
how they felt about anything i felt i
felt the dialogue was kind of poorly
written
i thought with the girl you didn't
notice that i just thought that the
girls
i i kind of perceived that everyone just
thought of him as harmless
um so i don't think they were attracted
to him or anything like that they just
thought he was some schlub that was
coming up taking pictures of them and
they didn't have any
like they just thought he was like a
little kid or like he didn't have any he
wasn't any threat to them maybe that's
kind of how i perceived it maybe it's
just another time maybe another era but
i don't know anybody that acts like that
or talks like that well and like
like i said too you have to think this
is not only like you know a different
country to us this is a uk which is not
all that different but you know
um but this was also like you know a
very long time ago that this movie
was made so you know it i so i don't
know like how much of it is like lost in
the translation because i was not alive
in 1960 you were not alive in 1960 yeah
i don't know anybody like that remember
the girl who
she was screwing around on her fiance
with her boyfriend the fiancee beat her
up she wanted to know if he could hide
the bruises
and just the way she's talking about it
or not really not really
you know it's like it wasn't a big deal
well i think they were trying to i feel
like
one of the main themes of the movie not
only voyeurism
and almost turning the audience into a
voyer akin to
mark which i think is what a lot of
critics found objectionable at the time
but i think they were also trying to
portray
maybe even the culture as a whole as
this kind of like degraded
because it's like these women are
getting beat up it's like a lot of the
women that he kills are
prostitutes or there's like deformed
women who are being models
that was just kind of odd i really
really couldn't really understand like i
didn't understand what what the director
was trying to do
i think they were trying to highlight
like the seedy underbelly
okay and and so so he was almost
i don't know if he was necessarily
making like a moral statement about look
how
degraded our culture is becoming yeah
but he might have been trying to
highlight that
as maybe mark is not only a product of
this but he's also like feeding upon
this new like oh yeah my
i have a like a boyfriend and a fiancee
and i just like ch
cheat on everybody and also he beat me
up and meh whatever
yeah so i do feel like he was kind of
maybe okay
saying saying that this type of culture
perhaps
produces yeah people right i didn't
really get it
on a cultural level i guess like i said
it didn't age as well i think
at least you know me just being [ __ ]
average american joe i didn't really
understand what he was saying
i mean i i could be perceiving it wrong
but that was the
perception that i i mean that was how i
write it
yeah because he was very deliberately
trying to because he made a lot of the
women other than
um you know the girl that lives
downstairs that
you know he actually like has feelings
for
other than that like pretty much every
other woman in there is either
a prostitute or someone who's just
posing for smut pictures
or is just kind of like um
you know the the one woman that he that
works with him that she's like the
stand-in for the actress of the movie
that he's working on
is just kind of she's not a terrible
person but she's very like free-spirited
like always kind of dancing around and
she's kind of like
she's like an actress type where she's
very like kind of high maintenance and
[ __ ] like that
so i feel like maybe that might be
that might be one thing that he was
trying to highlight that this is the way
the culture is going because nobody yeah
because that was a legal profession in
england in 1960 wouldn't it
i can't remember if when the law making
it illegal was passed or
making it legal as fast i can't really
remember when that was i remember
looking it up once but now i can't
remember when that was because you know
we're doing these true crime
episodes and a lot of the stuff that
happens in england i mean all they do is
just talk about
yeah this one worked as a prostitute and
that worked as a prostitute and i
you know mostly we're talking about 60s
and 70s and sometimes 80s
in england you know i thought that was
just legal and normal i guess that there
was lots of those
well i don't know about that i don't
know about it being legal
i mean it might be in the sense of you
know you just get a fine or people just
like hey knock it off or whatever
don't let us catch you again yeah it's
1960 which they do in a lot of uh
cities here as well it's 1960 and it's
england so
you know what i mean i was just saying
it to me i didn't understand that part
of it or what
what i didn't understand what the
director was trying to tell me tom found
it very interesting that the news agents
shop
that he works in that has like the
upstairs with like the illicit
you know uh photograph studio or
whatever that they basically just had
topless chicks like all over the front
of the
yeah of the thing yeah i thought it was
weird because
he's they've got topless photos photos
you know on the
in the windows like facing the streets
in the street
sure but then guys were sneaking in and
surreptitiously buying the same thing
the photos in there because they
couldn't really show those photos they
just had like some guy come in and
you know he wanted to buy some
newspapers and like hey you got any i
think he called them views
um so they had to keep that [ __ ] under
the counter they didn't show them but i
think
that those were like full nude or were
actually
like you know more porn like okay
because as far as i can recall and maybe
people from the uk can
correct me if i'm wrong but i always
thought the uk never really had much of
a problem at least with
breasts because pre i mean even in
regular newspapers you know that you
have the page three girl or whatever
which what what the [ __ ] is that daily
mirror i can't remember it was like one
of the main like dailies
and page three girl it was like every
day you'd have like this
chick with her [ __ ] titties hanging
out just like and any kid could like
walk in there and look at it
they didn't really seem to have i don't
think that there's a thing for like full
nudity like
or anything but i don't think they ever
really had a problem with breasts
yeah and see in american culture we
don't differentiate between porn you
know what it is when you see it
and bare-chested women would be
considered porn
there wouldn't be any real difference
between that and full nudity or even sex
it's it's all lumped into the
distinction nowadays
i mean well and honestly like i said i
wasn't alive back then but i
from my understanding i always thought
there was a difference between
just like a naked photo of a woman who's
just like standing there
um and porn which would actually show
either real or simulated intercourse
i think nowadays the distinction is like
erect penis
yeah it's it's it's weird i don't think
there's i don't i can't understand i
mean it's strange because like the line
it's a blurry line obviously but um
it's it's kind it's funny because it
kind of reminds me of
like the scenes where he was shooting
the women like upstairs
like for the photos because i'm assuming
that he's shooting the stuff for like
the underground [ __ ] which is supposed
to be like really but they're still like
fully clothed pretty much
um he did take one picture one one with
just like her boobs or whatever
but it reminds me a lot of um some of
like the ed wood movies like where
you know what i made where uh what was
that one i was thinking of the sinister
urge
where this dude is supposed to be like
this pornographic photographs that are
like causing this guy to be
a serial killer or whatever and it's
like they show this this kindly old man
like taking these pornographic pictures
and the women are totally dressed it's
like they have more on than like a
bathing suit
yeah and they're like covered up so i'm
like that's not porn that's like
lingerie catalog yeah that's not porn at
all
but it's like but see in the movie they
couldn't show that
right so they had to like imply because
they can't
show like porn obviously so it's like
they just have to imply oh this is porn
even though what is happening in your
mind though
okay a lot of fetish stuff involves
fully
clothed people but they got dudes that
are [ __ ] getting off on that
well yeah i mean because of what kind of
shoes she's got on yeah kind of this and
that
and i can understand that i know porn
when i see it even if they're not naked
well look at all the look at all the
stuff that betty page did it's like you
know they had pictures of her
topless or just you know and that was
fine but the s
m stuff she did yeah where she had like
the boots and the whip and everything
that had to be that had to be like under
the counter i can understand that
right because actually it's just full
nudity i don't really find that too
exciting actually but some of that
fetish was
wears a lot hotter well yeah than just
seeing like a naked woman
yeah just like yeah like even even in a
provocative yeah who gives a [ __ ]
there's like yeah
there's something more intense about
some of those clothes
just yeah i can yeah i totally agree
with you on that yeah especially
in the [ __ ] hat and the [ __ ] hats
and the [ __ ] kind of hair and
but i'm i'm a man i'm borderline
fetishist to begin with you know i mean
that's what i think most guys
are if you look at what guys are looking
at
even in anime and drawings it's not that
woman it's
it's it's how it's it's the it's the
packaging
yeah it's what they're wearing but i can
totally i'm not a dude but i totally
understand that
right i mean because like i said if i
was going to look at like erotic
photography or anything like that i
would want like
like cool costumes or like cool like
partially dressed and stuff like that
because like you said
you know it's going back thousands and
millions of years beauty
isn't natural
okay looking the natural natural stuff
isn't that beautiful [ __ ] women have
been
piercing themselves and putting
headdresses on
and wearing weird costumes going back
thousands of years
probably but scarification and body
tattoos
well yeah of course because because that
is enhancement
yeah and that's easier to do than make
clothing
thousands of years ago you know what i
mean they clothing probably wasn't real
practical in hot areas anyway so it was
just
body modifications yeah and you know
what tribal people think is good it
looks good is
not really the same as mainstream people
but it's equivalent to fetish clothing
or clothing
yeah which yeah that's so i think it's
i think it's just kind of ingrained into
humans going back you know
thousands of years hundreds of thousands
yeah but and
what's funny is that animals don't do
that only humans do that it's
like the extra it's extra yeah okay
they're putting something extra yeah on
it all right
the closest thing i would say that i've
ever seen like that in nature was
big old buck deer in rut trying to
pick up limbs with their antlers to make
it look like they got more antlers
it's really just a bunch of damage or
you could sticks and [ __ ] or you could
talk about like something like
bauer birds like somebody that like
where like the bird like builds
like a little house with a bunch of
shiny [ __ ] yeah a bunch of shiny stuff
and i think it's
that which i think that's adorable
that's it right he's like look i made
you a little pretty
they don't live in it or nothing it's
just in a way clothes are lit or that
yeah that's just like they don't birds
don't wear clothes and most people look
better in clothes than without clothes
so
that's what clothes are i think mostly
yeah nudity i don't think is
erotic i you know what i think i i kind
of agree with you on that yeah i see
what i'm seeing i'm saying well no yeah
i know usually
i know what you're saying like i said
that's there's a reason why like you
know s
m ware and [ __ ] like that is like pretty
much universally considered sexy because
yeah and i think that even goes down to
certain kind of street clothes of course
yeah you know you you dress a woman the
right
way if she's built the right way put the
tight enough t-shirt in the right pants
and the right shoes on the right hair
and the right makeup
she's hot she looks better like that
than she would look without those
clothes
yeah which yeah like i said i totally
always
yeah it's it's it's your whole like
gestalt your whole thing you got going
on
right so sometimes we start going back
into the 1960s for taking it back to the
movie you go back to the 1960s i'm not
sure how they were thinking
because i wasn't from that time yeah you
know what i mean yeah
i get i get what we're saying so i don't
know what they consider porn to be
like i'm a like i'm an alien from
another planet watching it was going
like what
but you know it kind of kind of
the thing is though is like when ed
woods talking about it and making movies
like you're talking about the past i
understand what he's talking about more
yeah then i understand
this because i know the culture yeah
well like i said
the us and the uk are not really that
different in that regard there were key
differences in the law though in the way
that's thinking in the culture
of what was acceptable and what wasn't
yeah and then how people would react
like i know how an old-fashioned
american would react to [ __ ]
right i don't know how an old-fashioned
british person would react to [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean well clearly
they uh really were upset by this i
don't think they
they weren't upset with the you know the
porn angle or the smut angle they
weren't upset with that
they were upset because one it made the
killer
almost sympathetic like you were
supposed to like understand her
sympathies with him which they didn't
really like
and i think also they didn't like being
put in the position
of being of seeing things from the
perspective of the killer because
uh in a lot of the movies and
particularly like in the very iconic
like opening scene um
you're seeing everything through his
camera because he films everything
and you know you're following this
prostitute like you know doing her ass
and stuff like that i think a lot of
critics didn't like being put in that
same position of being a voyer like he
was
i think that's what made people
uncomfortable it's weird if this ever
made it to the united states i think
they just would have [ __ ] cut the
boobs out they would have cut even the
pictures of the boobs on the [ __ ]
street
corners probably
[Laughter]
but i think they would have let it roll
maybe the time when he was threatening
some of them with knives they might have
cut that knife out
and just although psycho came out the
same year and psycho
i would argue that psycho is more
violent than that i think it is yeah
i think i think this movie could have
rolled in in america
yeah it had had they released it had not
everybody had such a [ __ ] fit about
it over there
that they just like they would have told
them that they would have cut out the
scenes that had any boobs
yeah or even pictures of boobs in the
scenes yeah they wouldn't they wouldn't
can't do that you can show all the
violence you want you
just can't show any titties couldn't
show you which is [ __ ] up
you couldn't show a picture of the titty
in the movie yeah so he came to show a
picture of it
in the movie titties are so much scarier
than murray
would have crossed into the line of
being porn right
yeah i know and it would have to apply
to those lost so then you would be
able you could have only shown it in a
porn theater yeah
so that's the sensor is what i said yeah
you got this seems like the kind of
movie even though like i said nowadays
it's very very tame
um it's not even as violent as psycho
like i said which came out the same year
um i think this would have been had it
been released in the us it probably
would have been relegated to like your
42nd street
you know uh you know grindhouse type
theaters not necessarily porn but just
like exploitation yeah
type films um i think that's probably
the only place i don't think they would
have shown it in like in a quote unquote
respectable yeah
they would have showed it in the same
place as they showed night of the living
dead yeah yeah yeah
that's that's what i mean that's what i
mean right you're you're you're you're
grinding
yeah it's a decent movie i think it was
a good template for things that came
later like [ __ ]
silence of the lambs yeah and serial
killer type movies where it's a little
bit more realistic about the serial
killer
it was important well like i said i
think this and psycho were one of the
this is really like one of the proto
slashers the one of the ones where
it actually because i think prior to
this and please correct me if i'm wrong
anybody that's like a film historian or
anything but i think
this movie and psycho might have been
the first two to actually
show a human killer that you were
actually interacted with for like a
large portion of the film because even
norman bates you could argue was
sympathetic and like had a [ __ ] up
life and you could kind of understand
like why he ended up like he did
so these might be the first because i
think prior to this really
yes there were murderers in movies and
stuff like that like going way the [ __ ]
back to the beginning of cinema
but they were always kind of shown as
pretty much straight up villains or
straight up evil
um i don't really know if there was any
film that went too much into showing
that they had any good qualities or any
positive qualities or any
reason or understanding about why they
ended up the way they ended up
you know what i'm saying there might
have been some before that but i just
feel like
these were the first ones to kind of
like take that and like put it right in
your face
because the thing about it is that going
back to
what uh what mark in this movie
basically what he's trying to do
he's trying to as i said he's trying to
continue his father's work
and so he films everything and he tells
several other characters like during the
movie that he's making a quote-unquote
documentary but he won't tell anybody
what it's about he's like oh well i'll
let you know what it's about when it's
when it's finished
what he does he wants to kill these
women he has like the
the camera and he has like a tripod
where the little thing uh the little
foot comes off and there's a blade in
there like on one thing at the tripod
and he also has like a mirror like on
top of the camera
so that because he's really into while
he's killing these women
he wants them to be able to see
themselves and like see their own death
so he's trying to get like the perfect
murder and the perfect like
encapsulation
of fear like in one like you know a
woman that knows she's about to die and
as she's dying
and at one point like this one woman he
kills her and he does the whole stabby
thing with the mirror and everything
and then he's watching the the film that
he made back later
and it's like [ __ ] up like the light
was messed up or something like that and
he just has like a total [ __ ]
meltdown about it
he's like now i have to do another one
because he's trying to find the perfect
one
and he can't do it something always goes
wrong so he always kind of has to like
find somebody else
and you know so so there's a thing too
where
um he almost kind of gets to because i
was going to say that the girl that
lives downstairs from him
that you know hip they kind of you know
strike up a relationship
and that girl has a blind mom
who like many blind characters in movies
knows
it has almost like psychic powers so she
like knows that this dude is there
there's something wrong with him like
from the jump
um so there's like a really good scene
where she like basically sneaks up into
his room and like has some [ __ ]
talking to
with him and he like almost kills her
and there's like other this other [ __ ]
too
so he tells this girl that he's into
basically
if he sees her looking afraid
then he like is gonna have to kill her
because that's just like his thing
so he has enough presence of mind and
has enough like warm feelings toward her
that when she starts to get scared of
him when she finds out like
what he's done when she like watches the
movies that you know that he has made
um he knows to like to put he's like get
behind me i don't want to like look at
your face because if i see you looking
afraid then i'll have to kill you
and so the fact that he comes to that
realization that this
you know he doesn't want to kill this
person is kind of what leads him to
his own destruction and killing himself
which
is like the ultimate you know this is
like the ultimate
goal of his like his life's work i guess
which is really [ __ ] up
but yeah so if you have not seen peeping
tom
and if you're into horror if you're into
slasher movies or anything like that
um you know it's on to be for free uh if
you want to watch it
it's a very like you said it's it's
dated it's
um it's a really beautiful it's like
it's a beautifully
framed looking movie like it almost
because it has those like saturated like
eastman color
hues and everything like almost like a
mario baba movie like the way it's like
you know lit and everything like that
it's like really really gorgeous
um so yeah i mean in a lot of ways it's
dated it's very tame by today's
standards it's not even as violent as
psycho like i said
but you can see between this movie and
psycho
it's interesting to uh see how how
the two movies were received
like in their respective cultures and
as i said these two movies were actually
like really really instrumental in
developing this whole like more
humanized
monster type of thing like in horror
movies my only criticism of the movie
itself is that
the edit is a little ponderous
towards the end as it starts to go
if you were to compare it to psycho
psycho has a much more compelling pace
for me you know it all has to do with
taste
you know what i mean for me um there's a
little too much movie in this movie if
you understand
[Laughter]
i think it could have been kind of sped
up a little bit
but you you um you have to look at this
in the context of the day that it was
made back in 60s
they let [ __ ] unfold a lot longer i'm
like okay come on kill somebody
get some [ __ ] done i know you're crazy
just kill somebody and let's let this
[ __ ] go
people didn't have they didn't really
they didn't have attention deficit
destruction back then
right uh if this movie would have made
today
that would the edit would have been a
lot faster i'm kind of interested that
no one as far as i know has ever remade
this
did somebody remake it i don't think
they did it would
you could remake something like this
certain certain ideas would have to be
tossed out
i think you could remake this but i
think you know in the subsequent years
because we've had so many movies kind of
like this
i don't think it would stand out i mean
obviously it stood out so much in 1960
because nobody had seen anything like
this before
um you know just putting you in the
shoes of a serial killer and making you
feel what he felt and like almost kind
of like empathize with him to a degree
and i think that that was very offensive
to people at the time they just like
weren't [ __ ] ready for it like i said
psycho did
a similar thing but for some reason that
was like hugely lauded although i think
even psycho when it came out got like a
lot of [ __ ] on it too but
it it didn't get [ __ ] on nearly as much
as this
psycho is a tighter movie if you ask me
um would agree with you
a little more intense it's a little more
driving um but like i said
everything is to taste but for me i i
think most people would say that psycho
is a better
movie uh yeah i think most people would
agree with you on that but like i said
you know it's just instructive to see
how two different cultures approached
essentially the same it's not the same
story but it's like a similar
type of story a tip you know a
psychological [ __ ] that's like
examining
i kind of see this one is more kind of
like a silence of the lambs of its time
yeah that's yeah that's a pretty astute
option i think it'd be a little bit more
like that
now sometimes you guys might see some
edits in this actual
show that we've done i'm cooking
something so i have to keep coming out
he has to keep
and making sure i'm not burning the damn
house he didn't say anything i'm talking
about i'm like look i gotta go man
[ __ ] they're gonna check on that
but you know sometimes [ __ ] happens you
could have interrupted you said
you don't usually have a thing about it
i wanted to make cooking part of the
show on this episode
but uh we do have to i do have to shut
this down i gotta get i get back in
yeah okay so uh yeah so if you're into
horror if you're into slasher movies and
you want to see like one of the very
early like proto slasher movies if
you've already seen psycho but you
haven't seen this one
then definitely check out peeping tom
from 1960 as i said it's free on to be
might be on some other uh platforms as
well
but yeah go check it out and we'll see
you on the next one bye
you